hey guys my name is just mcdonald today
the 15th of April and your change into
games what news we love to see the
publisher Giants get alone here at
GameSpot and today Xboxes phil spencer
had some nice things to say about sony
exclusive blood-borne it's safe to say
most of you are fans of the game and
happy to see it too so well and xbox
executive phil spencer counts himself
among year the news came in yesterday
that blood-borne had sold through 1
million copies and spencer took to
twitter to say quote i know some will
question me but wanted to say it's cool
to see blood-borne sell 1 million plus
new IP is hard Congrats playstation and
from software the game's producer Misaki
yamakawa posted on the playstation blog
yesterday to emphatically thank fans for
playing and enjoying the game Game Stop
are all set to start buying and selling
retro consoles so if you want a piece of
history or you've already got something
and want to make some cash is your
chance a short while ago the retailer
opened up a ps2 trade ins and now
according to IGN they're moving forward
with a plan to include a lot more retro
consoles the program is currently only
going ahead in New York City and
Birmingham come April 25 customers in
those regions will be able to trade in
their 1985 Nintendo Entertainment System
Super Nintendo Sega Genesis original
PlayStation Nintendo 64 and Sega
Dreamcast if you're worried your old
beloved consoles will be sent off to a
farm never to return the plan is to have
them shipped to the retailers
refurbishment operations center where
they will be inspected and repaired if
necessary as for the buying side the
retro consoles and games will be sold
online so no need to get your hands on a
ticket to New York
there's no word yet on how much you'll
be paying or be paid for the retro
consoles and games in question for those
of you who thought the Natural Resources
Defense Council went a little far in
criticizing the power consumption of the
Xbox one this saga is far from over as I
told you a few days
ago Microsoft outlined their plans to
offer consumers the chance to change to
an energy saving mode and lose the
instant on speeches when they set up
their consult NRDC senior scientist Noah
Horowitz has called this great news
but he takes issue with the positive
phrasing in the instant-on option and
the focus on the negative outcomes of
the energy saving option like slower
startup time
Horowitz has also said the energy
consumption levels for each option
should be included that is 12.5 watts
for instant-on versus less than one watt
for energy saving the NRDC is calling
from Microsoft to reduce the instant-on
consumption to one what and make the
energy-saving option the default
they've also pointed out that Microsoft
need to cut down on the power allocated
to enabling the Xbox one to be woken up
via a Kinect voice command now I'm a fan
of the environment but I'm making an
educated guess that Microsoft probably
isn't interested in removing one of
their signature features to save power
let me know down in the comments what
you think of this whole energy
consumption debate and where you'd like
to see Microsoft go from yeah you can
educate us for we've got news on an
honest bloodborne trailer and the
developers of Ori and the blind forest
wanting to make a better war game that's
everything I wanted to tell you about
today thanks for tuning in as always and
I'll catch you same time tomorrow